[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le jeudi à 10 février et
l'actualité à la une bien sûr c'est la
qualification et du football-club de
versailles en demi finale de la coupe de
france les yvelinois ont battu hier
bergerac en quarts de finale au terme
d'une séance de tirs aux buts 1 but
partout à l'issue du temps réglementaire
sedira souba qui avait donné l'avantagé
aux versaillais au quart d'heure de jeu
avant l'égalisation périgourdine en fin
de rencontre c'est seulement la
cinquième fois dans l'histoire qu'une
équipe de 4e division atteint le dernier
carré de la compétition et versailles
qui recevra l'ogcnice le troisième de
ligue 1 en demi finale la rencontre est
au programme le 2 mars et devrait bien
se disputer en région parisienne reste à
déterminer dans quel stade le stade
charléty le parc des princes et le stade
de france on les pistes évoquées nous
sommes revenus longuement un déjà sur ce
moment historique pour le football
yvelinois dans notre édition spéciale de
tout à l'heure elle est à revoir sur
notre site internet et notre application
mobile
[Musique]
les concertations se poursuivent à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines autour du
futur site olympique de la colline
d'elancourt prévu pour accueillir les
épreuves de vtt pour paris 2024 il faut
avant le début des travaux répondre aux
enjeux concernant l'écologie
l'aménagement et l'héritage du lieu le
point avec bixente maria santis est
bonne elle accueillera les jeux
olympiques de paris 2024 mais avant la
colline d'elancourt devra être aménagé
plus de 350 ils en ont participé ces
derniers mois à des concertations avant
la validation du projet par
l'agglomération objectif transmettre
leurs interrogations leurs inquiétudes
et apporter de nouvelles idées nous
allons ensuite soumettre le résultat des
études à un vote qui serait deux fois ci
à une prise de position qui sera
électronique pour la population qui aura
lieu pendant tout le printemps 2022 à
nouveau nous allons pouvoir débriefer
l'ensemble des interventions avant la
fermeture du site pour travaux en 2023
ces discussions ont permis de confirmer
les impératifs en vue de la
transformation et ce qu'ont donné les
différentes études réalisées et le
retour des habitants bien c'est la même
la même orientation la volonté de
conserver un parc ouvert à la population
vers vertueux est donc un maximum
d'efforts a été mis a été confiée mais
par les résultats des études de fait
auprès de la population de la volonté de
densifier encore la protection de
l'environnement c'est pourquoi les ce
que j'appelle la compensation écologique
sur ce site sur un certainement une des
composantes station écologique les plus
exemplaires que de tout paris 2024 autre
interrogation l'héritage après les jeux
et comment mettre en relief le futur
espace sportif le site a été pensé pour
pouvoir une fois que les jeux olympiques
sont terminés donc il soit ouvert au
public mais également que l'ensemble des
infrastructures invisible tout ce qui
permet techniquement de pouvoir très
rapidement réinstaller un lieu d'accueil
des preuves de vtt soit présent tout ce
qui est passage des câbles tout ce qui
est r techniques etc mais ça sera
absolument invisible permettront demeure
de pouvoir bien positionné à nouveau
très rapidement un village pour un
week-end de vtt et pourquoi pas une voix
cueillir par exemple les championnats du
monde de vtt en plus du vtt à elancourt
dans les yvelines accueilleront le bmx
le cyclisme sur piste et sur route le
pentathlon moderne le golf et les sports
équestres cette épreuve olympique dont
celle d'elancourt sous l'oeil de la
grande dame de fer
mais des révélations sur un système qui
maltraitent nos aînés dans son livre les
fossoyeurs le journaliste
d'investigation victor castanet pointe
du doigt plusieurs grands groupes
spécialisés dans l'hébergement des
personnes âgées notamment le groupe
orpea pour des faits de maltraitance et
de rationnement plus récemment c'est le
groupe korian qui a été visé par des
plaintes pour parler de ce sujet en
plateau avec moi didier baichère bonsoir
bonsoir député de la première
circonscription des yvelines vous est
également membre de la commission des
affaires sociales à l'assemblée
nationale et vous vous êtes d'ailleurs
rendu aujourd'hui dans l'ehpad les
saules à guyancourt qui appartient au
groupe korian depuis la sortie du livre
il ya eu beaucoup de plaintes
aujourd'hui plusieurs familles sont
inquiètes quelle est votre position face
à ces pratiques dénoncées et comment
rassurer les familles finalement elle le
meilleur moyen de rassurer les familles
déjà c'est d'aller sur le terrain moi
c'est ma 3e 4e rencontres avec les ehpad
de montigny et de guyancourt du groupe
korian parce que c'est vrai qu'aux
rayons étaient présents sur sur la vie
de nouvelles et j'avais vraiment à coeur
d'aller à la fois rencontrer les équipes
soignantes parce que c'est aussi un
secteur où il est difficile de recruter
cas pas toujours une très bonne image
est là preuve avec ce qu'on dit
aujourd'hui les difficultés de
recrutement vont continuer donc j'ai
vraiment eu un échange sans filtre avec
avec les équipes soignantes donc et
d'accompagnement donc c'était plutôt
très bien et puis la possibilité de
discuter aussi avec les familles des
résidents je dois dire que le groupe
korian a joué vraiment la transparence
la presse était présente donc a pu
constater les faits moi je crois qu'il
ya ait pas d pad il faut pas mettre tout
le monde dans le même sac tu as des
faits isolés oui en plus sur la région
parisienne il faut il faut voir que
orpea ça représente 8 % en fait des
ehpad on n'est pas concerné dans le 78
le groupe porté à napa de
d'établissement dans le 78 c'est vrai
que pour avoir participé puisque nous
avons un cycle d'auditions actuellement
à l'assemblée nationale l'audition du
groupe orpea c'était quand même assez
surréaliste il faut le dire je crois que
on a une démonstration en fait de
parfait gestionnaire financier mais très
éloigné en fait du bien être des
résidents ce qui en tout cas à toutes
mes rencontres depuis 2010 est avec les
ehpad de saint quentin en yvelines je
n'ai pas du tout eu ce sentiment est
encore aujourd'hui
enfin j'ai pu mesurer en tout cas qu'au
sol il y avait vraiment une
bienveillance un intérêt pour la santé
des patients et essayer de s'organiser
vous savez que au sol quasiment 90 % des
résidents sont des résidents de saint
quentin en yvelines versailles viroflay
grand maximum donc on est aussi sur des
gens qui souhaitent continuer à vivre là
où ils ont vécu toute leur vie avec leur
famille donc c'est un élément important
c'est cette proximité je trouve enfin de
voilà que l'offre elle soit disponible
sur notre sur notre territoire alors
suite au scandale une enquête a été
ouverte par la commission des affaires
sociales de l'assemblée nationale
où en est-on aujourd'hui là on est on
est sur un cycle effectivement
d'audition on à moi j'ai été très
marquée cette semaine par l'audition de
la rs donc l' agence régionale de santé
d'île de france avec qui on a pu
partager notre inquiétude sur la
nécessité de mettre en place un certain
nombre de certifications et
d'indicateurs comme il ya pour les
hôpitaux mais qui n'existe pas dans les
ehpad alors l'appareil le groupe korian
qui est un très grand groupe a devancé
un certain nombre d'éléments et à une
certification iso 9001 donc on voit bien
que tous les états ne sont pas logés à
la même enseigne ce qu'il faut bien
avoir en tête c'est qu'aujourd'hui nous
avons un cinquième de la population
française qui a plus de 65 ans à
l'horizon 2030 c'est un quart de la
population française qui aura plus de 65
ans donc on a un vrai phénomène
démographique qui fait que et c'est ce
qui nous a poussés en 2021 a créé la
cinquième branche de la sécurité sociale
donc cette 5ème branche qui rassemble
l'ensemble des financements les 31
milliards de la dépendance dans un seul
bloc pourquoi parceque il va y avoir un
besoin d'investissement gigantesque
confère ce que je disais sur la
démocratie sur la démographie pardon et
aussi parce que les députés à
l'assemblée nationale nous avons besoin
de pouvoir suivre les contres de pouvoir
suivre les actions est telle que cet
effet jusqu'à maintenant en fait vous
aviez une dispersion des actifs
financiers un peu partout une vraie
difficulté à suivre ce qui se passait en
termes de dépendance je disais tout à
l'heure vous étiez cet après midi elle
n'est pas de les saules de guyancourt
c'est un établissement du groupe korian
il compte aujourd'hui 100 ciliées
embauche 68 professionnel patrick
jacques de dixmude et nicolas landry ont
pu interroger la directrice de
l'établissement
nous avons des résidents qui sont la
soumet tout le temps ils habitent ici ce
sont leurs lieux de vie ils reçoivent
leur famille ils font des repas avec
leur famille au sein de la structure les
familles ont la possibilité de venir
déjeuner ils sortent ils vont en
vacances ils reviennent ils vont passer
les week-ends en famille nous avons des
activités qui sont proposées dans les
étages avec les soignants qui font des
activités des journées vous avez un
animateur qui est là aussi qui fait
l'activité temps et vous avez ce que
nous avons un point d'activité en seront
adaptés ce ne sont pas des on va dire
c'est vraiment m'aider à les capacités
préserver de nos résidents
[Musique]
il yal amalgame de tout alors que ce
n'est pas lié à tous les ehpad c'est
toute la profession qui est touché 1 par
rapport à ça mais ils se disent qu'ils
ne sont pas concernés voilà ils ne se
sentent pas concernés ils ne se
reconnaissent pas à travers ce type de
pratiques et on se reconnaît pas non
plus chez korn ya les solins ce non pas
du tout mais même les familles peuvent
vous le dire
nous avons notre psychologue donc qui
est référente justement bientraitance
pas plus tard que le dit elle avait déjà
organisé deux formations avec les
équipes 1 donc et aussi vous avez corion
donc nous avons pas mal de formations
dans le catalogue de formations korian
et donc nous avons ce qu'on appelle des
formations best dont une partie avec
justement la bientraitance de nos aînés
mais vous le dit didier baichère vous
avez pu échanger avec les équipes sur
place dans quel état d'esprit sont elles
aujourd'hui j'ai trouvé des équipes très
mobilisés parce qu'encore une fois il ya
une vraie dynamique d'équipé à l'ehpad
des saules mais on a on a effectivement
mis sur la table le manque de moyens en
personnel parce que quand je leur ai
posé la question si vous deviez me
communiquer vraiment un élément de
difficultés pour vous dans votre
quotidien on a parlé de la nécessité
d'augmenter le nombre d'encadrants ou de
soignants par par résident qui était
présent et c'est vraiment tout l'enjeu
c'est à dire que dans le budget 2022 on
a voté 400 millions supplémentaires pour
financer 20 mille postes supplémentaires
dans les ehpad mais aussi vingt mille
service civique parce que ce que nous
visons aussi c'est d'amener des jeunes à
regarder différemment ce type de métier
pour ensuite s'engager de manière
beaucoup plus durable dans les métiers
alors du soin du caire enfin il n'y a
pas que pour les ehpad il ya aussi dans
dans les établissements de médico
sociaux on a besoin de recruter donc il
ya un effort budgétaire certains qui qui
est présent un besoin de recrutement
mais nous devrons aussi avancer c'était
tout l'enjeu de l'audition avec la rs
cette semaine sur la certification sur
des indicateurs pour pouvoir mesurer
d'un ehpad à l'autre qu'est ce qui
fonctionne et qu'est ce qui fonctionne
pas et comment s'améliorer dans le temps
pour s'assurer qu'on a des ehpad ou la
bienveillance est vraiment la clé de ce
qui est ce qu'il y ait demandé en fait
partie selon dernière chose dans un
communiqué vous vous appelez à mettre en
place un système de certification pour
les ehpad comme il existe pour les
hôpitaux ça serait une solution peut
être plus vigilant peut-être en tout cas
c'est un moyen de contrôle des finances
publiques si on n'a pas d'indicateur et
si on dit pas parce qu'il s'agit
d'établissements à but lucratif qui on
confie de l'argent public il faut
absolument que nous on est des
indicateurs et que eux mêmes sache sur
quels indicateurs ils vont être mesurée
aujourd'hui il ya vraiment pas c'est un
peu la foire dans ce domaine là donc il
faut qu'on arrive à mettre un peu
d'ordre y a pas forcément besoin d'un
texte de loi en plus pour mettre des
indicateurs en place donc c'est plutôt
une bonne nouvelle parce que c'est des
choses qui peuvent se mettre en place
rapidement
on est tous concernés on est tous
concernés parce que évidemment on
vieillit on est tous concernés parce que
dans nos familles on a tous eu à se
poser la question pour nos parents
comment ça va se passer
cette fin de vie elle doit être heureuse
et bienveillante et c'est un enjeu moi
c'est un véritable enjeu de société
alors est ce que ce sera un enjeu de la
présidentielle je n'en sais rien mais je
pense que c'est quelque chose en tout
cas auquel on doit apporter une réponse
et qui préoccupe beaucoup de français le
thème dont on parlera de plus en plus
dans les annes avis on l'a compris et en
cas de besoin après c'est juste que pour
lutter contre les maltraitances envers
les personnes âgées il est il existe un
numéro vert ans et le 39 77 à un numéro
qui est anonyme et gratuit merci didier
baichère d'être venu en plateau je
rappelle député de la première
circonscription des yvelines également
membre de la commission des affaires
sociales à l'assemblée nationale
[Musique]
cette information de nos confrères de
7,8 actu avant de vous laisser fermeture
à venir pour le vaccinodromes de saint
quentin en yvelines le méga centre voit
une nette baisse de fréquentation depuis
plusieurs semaines avec environ 500
injections par jour après le 25 février
la vaccination devrait se poursuivre
auprès des médecins infirmiers et
pharmaciens au début du mois le site
avait franchi le seuil des 400 milles
injection voilà c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de votre fidélité belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]